تطبيق وتيك توك واحد من اشهر التطبيقات
الاجتماعيه المستخدمه في العالم حقق نجاحا
كبيرا خلال الفتره الاخيره خاصه بين
الشباب والاطفال ومع ذلك فان هذا التطبيق
يشكل مخاطر كثيره ولا ينبغي التعامل معه
بشكل طائش يقول خبراء يحتوي تيك توك
مشاهدينا على العديد من التحديات المختلفه
التي تشجع المستخدمين على القيامه بانشطه
خطره مثل القفز من الاماكن العاليه وهذا
يمكن ان يؤدي طبعا الى الاصابات الجسديه
وحتى الموت يمكن للمستخدمين ان ينشروا
معلومات خاصه عن انفسهم او عن اصدقائهم
دون ان يدركوا المخاطر التي يتعرضون لها
حيث يمكن استخدام هذه المعلومات بطرق غير
مشروعه كالسرقه والاحتيال والتزوير يمكن
ايضا ان يؤدي استخدام تيك توك لفترات
طويله الى الادمان والانعزال الاجتماعي
كما يحصل مع الاطفال ويمكن ان يؤثر ذلك
على الصحه النفسيه والعقليه للمستخدم لكن
مشاهدينا كل ما سبق من مخاطر لا ينطبق على
تيك توك فقط بل ايضا على كافه وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي اذا لم تستخدم بحكمه
وكل تلك المخاطر لم تكن السبب وراء حاضر
التطبيق في كثير من الدول وانما السبب
الرئيسي يعود الى التحدي الامني واستخدام
المعلومات الشخصيه من قبل الحكومه الصينيه
[موسيقى]